i do want to welcome a new sponsor to
our program it's a new winery
right here in california they've got a
great product that's terrific
for this moment right now take a look a
great victory
deserves a great champagne for all the
other victories
there's modesto champagne with 30
fewer bubbles and a softer cork pop
modesto champagne celebrates your
smaller accomplishments you got into
your safety school
you pass your driver's test on the
fourth try it's the
not so bad kind of herpes
modesto is the only american sparkling
wine that can legally be called
champagne
after france's domain of origin control
board declared that it poses quote
no competitive or commercial threat so
whether you're celebrating your 37th
birthday
a lateral promotion or christening the
boat
you bought on craigslist get the
champagne critics have called
passable fine for the price and not good
slash
not bad modesto champagne the official
champagne of trump's second place finish
in the u.s election
you